celui qui a toujours été perçu comme un
bon deuxième nomme honnête et fiable
mais peu charismatique sera le prochain
adversaire du flamboyant d'un autre
homme natif de pennsylvanie il était
avocat au delà were quand il a été élu
pour la première fois sénateur en 1972
il a été réélu sans interruption à ce
poste à sept reprises en grande partie à
cause de sa personnalité simple et
chaleureuse des photos jean avec les
gens très simples john parisella ex
délégué général du québec à new york a
rencontré joe biden en 2011 lors d'une
soirée électorale
il a retenu l'image d'un homme politique
affable et charmant c'était un
assemblage personnes qui essaient de
trouver des compromis une personne cas
c'est de faire avancer les choses et il
est respecté par les gens de l'autre
côté de la chambre des le publicain ya
développé des grands initiés au fil des
années avec mickey avec le zikr m il
tente d'obtenir une première fois
l'investiture démocrate pour la
présidence en 1987 sans succès derrière
michael dukakis il joue un rôle dans
l'adoption des lois pour combattre la
criminalité et la violence domestique
sous la présidence de bill clinton
il reste perçu comme un homme de famille
surtout à cause de la perte successive
de sa première femme et d'une fille dans
un accident de voiture puis en 2015 de
son fils beau procureur général du
delaware et militaires mobilisés en irak
connu pour ses manières chaleureuse
parfois excessive avec les femmes
il a même été accusé d'agression
sexuelle par une ancienne collaboratrice
nord une usine à tubes des allégations
qui ne semble pas avoir eu de prise
jusqu'à maintenant chez les électeurs
démocrates
en juin dernier la sénatrice et
candidates kamala harris a durement
écorcher son rival joe biden en
rappelant son opposition
lancement public du transport scolaire
les écoliers de milieux défavorisés
rigole moins ça n'a pas empêché le
gagnant de la course de faire d'elle sa
colistière pour la campagne qui démarre
john rooney
on voit déjà la ligne d attaque de base
de donald trump contre le candidat
buydens ils le surnomment joe lando
remis ou jamais il va nous griller 7
heures cette ferveur que monsieur obama
va faire que pouvait faire et à un autre
moment dans l'histoire que j'enlève
qu'elle ait dit pas faire mais c'est une
personne qui met l'accent beaucoup ceux
des seuls élus citent faire avancer les
choses
à défaut de créer l'enthousiasmé joba et
de ne joue la carte du président de
réconfort après des années de grande
turbulence
sylvain desjardins radio canada montréal